it's 1762 John Montague is the fourth
Earl of Sandwich a small parish in the
southwest of England
despite his keen administrative skills
Montague is a corrupt politician an
adulterous husband and an incessant
degenerate gambler often while Monti was
in the midst of a particularly
high-stakes game he will insist on being
served his meals at the table in a
moment vision though likely inspired by
his travels the Earl orders his meat and
cheese be brought to him stacked between
two slices of bread so that he may eat
with one hand while continuing to gamble
with the other in one notorious episode
Montagu spends a full day and night
gambling it is during this infamous 24
hours of the gaming table that
Montague's characteristic hand-held
concession is dubbed the sandwich
according to one estimate Americans now
consume more than 300 million sandwiches
every day
you